being a video archivist for the scp
foundation is one of the easiest jobs in
the entire organization you're
responsible for viewing every tape found
in the field every interview with an
anomaly and every event log recorded by
a mobile task force if something passes
your desk that means the foundation's
going to want its contents viewed
transcribed and the original source
footage stored for preservation compared
to the doctors working tirelessly to
push their research to the boundaries of
understood science and field agents
risking their lives elsewhere your job
of lounging in an air-conditioned room
sitting at a computer and watching
videos all day seems pretty appealing at
least on paper it does when you take
into account just what it is you'll be
transcribing the grim realities present
in all foundation careers starts to
emerge in your deceptively cushy office
gig it's no secret that the foundation's
visual logs describe unspeakable horrors
within disgusting body alterations gory
details and terrifying imagery are
mainstays of foundation files most are
never conscious of the fact that every
log that's been written out had to have
been viewed by someone in the first
place those blank redacted areas where
your imagination has to fill in the
details
somewhere someone in the foundation had
to describe that sensitive information
in the first place that gruesome kill in
the task force report the visual
archivist saw the footage before they
wrote it out sure your job might be to
watch the foundation's home movies all
day but due to the sheer amount of
visual materials the foundation needs to
transcribe and catalog you'll be on
average seeing far more horrors than the
typical researcher or task force member
instead of being assigned to one or two
projects at a time you'll witness an
infinite slew of footage from across the
foundation's history you'll just be
viewing all of the horror from a
distance behind a screen after the fact
but you don't need to be told that
you're a professional hard-boiled
grizzled veteran of the foundation you
watch hours of footage a day transcribe
it archive it and send it out to be
inserted in the various articles and
files in the foundation database you've
lived through countless task force
missions observed endless testing logs
and seen everything from unimaginable
entities to the bloodiest events ever
taken place it used to keep you up at
night but at this point you're
desensitized to almost anything the
world can throw at you maybe that's why
you were the foundation's latest choice
to transcribe the footage recovered from
the site of scp-6670
you'd heard the stories a series of
tapes the other archivists were flat-out
refusing to transcribe due to sheer
disgust and horror they'd been passed
down the line two or three times and now
they came to you in a box of literal vhs
tapes labeled with a strip of tape that
read
scp-6670 recovered media you didn't
doubt that whatever was on these was
intense since it was enough to get a few
foundation archivists to pass something
that rarely happens but you were sure
they weren't anything you couldn't
handle you inspect the box for a
manifest paper to see if you can gain
any other information about the tapes
most of the time the varying parts of
the foundation's research is kept
heavily indiscernible from one another
the right hand never knows what the left
is doing so getting any further context
to the footage you're about to review is
oftentimes necessary but the paper
inserted on top of the box doesn't
reveal much it reads footage recovered
from the discovery site of
scp-667
containment site 86 detroit michigan
that's about as much as you're going to
get but at least it's something you take
the tape that says first on it and pop
it into the vcr yeah you had to dust off
that old dinosaur just for this the real
anomaly is that it still works after all
these years the first tape is overlaid
with a title that takes up the entirety
of the screen happy birthday gemma 1988
it reads the camera pans to a small
infant laying down on a cushion you can
tell from the brief glimpses of the
background that the house is dilapidated
poorly held together not the conditions
a child should be raised in but an
unfortunate reality that some face the
baby stares at the camera wiggling and
making adorable baby noises you wonder
if this is gemma the birthday girl
herself your thoughts are confirmed by
the camera holder who plays with and
tickles gemma celebrating her birthday
the camera holder asks the baby to smile
for mommy which the little gemma
gleefully does of course the one holding
the camera is gemma's mother and the two
are celebrating her first birthday the
rest of the tape is ordinary with gemma
and her mother playing and laughing
together her mother sings happy birthday
to her and the recording stops well that
wasn't so bad you think to yourself in
fact taking into account most of the
stuff that passes your desk that was
pretty good but that was only the first
tape you're intrinsically drawn to the
next one wondering how this could
possibly inspire so much fear in the
others who watched it second tape the
shot opens up with a woman dressed in a
slightly tattered sewn together formal
attire she's filming herself standing
before a mirror the title reads job
interview practice tape after the title
disappears she begins talking to herself
she reveals her name
melanie jamie g parker and acts as if
she's applying to a job specifically to
an internship at the walter media
broadcast company you can tell from the
sound of her voice that this is gemma's
mother melanie's mock interview proceeds
slowly she's visibly apprehensive chokes
over her words and seems to be in great
distress melanie mentions that she
turned 18 the other day and that she's
interested in applying for a job as a
news reporter still she can't get the
words out properly stuttering and
hesitating she's clearly distracted by
something off camera midway through her
rehearsal the sound of high-pitched
crying is heard it's the baby melanie
assures gemma that she's coming and
leans over to hit the button to stop the
recording before rushing off to calm
down the crying child again nothing
horrible you think it's difficult to
watch someone so young struggle with the
challenges of motherhood but it hasn't
made you lose your lunch or anything you
take out the third tape pop it in and
see what happens next another title a
letter to my family cut this seems like
it was intended to be thrown out the
picture comes in showing a crying melony
sitting on the edge of her bed in a
white gown
sniffling up her tears melanie delivers
a message intended to be viewed by her
family you learn that her relationship
with them is unstable and that melanie
has been on her own for months
potentially longer she musters out an
apology to her parents saying that she's
sorry about everything for a party for
stealing their money she continues to
cry but tells them that she wants them
to know that she's sorry and that she
loves them she addresses her sister's
caring attitude and her mother's smile
but is hesitant to compliment her father
she reveals that she hasn't spoken to
them in two years but she can't go any
longer she's barely been able to afford
basic necessities and despite applying
for as many jobs as she could she hasn't
landed one her personal savings are
almost depleted and she can't sleep at
night gemma's getting bigger a lot
bigger than any girl should be a two
she's rapidly outgrowing her clothes and
melanie's unable to provide her with the
love and care that she needs she's
halfway through saying that she wants
her parents to take custody of gemma but
she stops she can't get herself to admit
it she stares at the camera shakes her
head and begins cursing melanie's voice
gets louder and she vehemently defends
her decision to keep gemma for herself
she's not subjecting herself to her
family who she clearly despises melanie
continues to lash out against her family
saying that she's tired of them and that
they will never find her and gemma she's
visibly shaking her voice unstable
melanie's made her decision gemma's
staying with her she makes a statement
you should have seen how happy gemma and
i were how nice life is out here
the sun's so much brighter
there's no
no fighting no screaming
no crying
i took my daughter and i left all of you
and i am happy in the background gemma's
crying is heard again from another room
melanie drain looks in the distance
surprised to hear that she's awake she
wipes the tears from her eyes and
assures gemma that her mother will be
right there she forgets to turn the
camera off and rushes out of the room
for the rest of the tape lasting nearly
two hours in duration melanie calms
gemma holding her and assuring her that
she's safe eventually the camera's
battery gives out and the recording
stops so far it's definitely upsetting
to see but you haven't encountered
anything anomalous yet maybe it's the
fourth tape that will shed some light on
what's going on here you put it in and
prepare for the worst this tape cuts in
immediately without a title gemma and
melanie are playing together in
melanie's bedroom what she said about
gemma's growth is too she's only two but
she stands at four feet tall with long
and disheveled blonde hair gemma runs
across the bedroom making noises and
pretending to be an airplane melanie for
once doesn't seem to be stressed though
she looks visibly tired the sound of a
phone ringing is heard in the background
melanie immediately snaps out of her
happy attitude and runs off to answer it
while she talks on the phone gemma is
seen peering into a small hole in the
wall of the bedroom she then moves off
screen while melanie is talking on the
phone gemma tries to get her mother's
attention when melanie hangs up she
notices that she doesn't see her
daughter anywhere and begins frantically
searching gemma answers her voice coming
from inside the hole in the wall melanie
tries to goat her child from outside the
wall but gemma doesn't listen eventually
she hears a loud snap and then a scream
melanie panics moving her head into the
hole gemma cries screaming that she's in
pain and that she hurts something
melanie tells her that she'll get help
and desperately tries not to panic she
runs off screen and for 15 minutes all
that's heard is gemma crying melanie
returns with a young man who would later
be identified as her neighbor john bates
he carries a rope melanie directs bates
to a hole in the wall the two are
clearly familiar with one another and
melanie assures gemma that mr john is
going to help her out of the hole bates
kneels on the floor and inserts his head
into the wall feeding the rope inside
the hole on the count of three they tell
gemma to grab the rope and they'll pull
seconds pass without a response and
suddenly bates feels a tug she's
grabbing the rope melanie and bates pull
together hoping to lift gemma out of
wherever she fell but the girl won't
move she continues to cry saying that
she's stuck and neither bates nor
melanie can get her to budge melanie who
is now crying assures gemma that they'll
get her out while bates is more
reluctant bates tells her that they
aren't going to be able to get her out
by themselves and the two begin to argue
loudly they agree to call the fire
department after all they're specialized
in getting people out of confined spaces
bates tries calling but the lines are
full meanwhile melanie continues to lose
hope bates insists that they have to
call 9-1-1 but melanie knows that she
doesn't have enough to cover medical
costs and if they discover the living
conditions that gemma's been in they'll
surely take her child away the two
continue to argue bates suggests that
melanie phones her family which is the
ultimate breaking point for her from off
off-screen you can hear a struggle the
sound of a cupboard opening and then
baits hitting the floor 30 minutes of
silence follow when melanie returns
she's caked in dirt grease and blood
what happened was evident melanie sticks
her head inside the hole in the wall and
assures gemma that her mother will take
care of her the next day pulls you in
the title displays happy birthday gemma
1991.
you recognize that the video is being
taken from inside the wall there's a
small lava lamp and a cupcake with a
candle in front of gemma who lays prone
on the ground she's more pale than
before and looks to be about five feet
tall now and her shoulders encompass the
length of the space from behind the
camera melanie sings to her and gemma
blows out the candle the recording stops
another tape happy birthday gemma 1993.
gemma's looking visibly ill her eyes
droop she smiles tiredly and her body
seems to be larger than the space it's
confined to a cake sits in front of her
with five candles melanie sings to her
again the 1997 birthday tape is even
worse gemma is about seven feet tall and
her face encompasses the entire hole
with no discernible head melanie sings
to gemma who just wants to eat her cake
the sound of gemma's bones clinking and
cracking as her body contorts to the
tight space is heard the next tape is
unlabeled but the foundation determined
it to be recorded around 2001.
melanie sits outside the door to her
bedroom sobbing her bedroom is entirely
inaccessible behind the door the
cracking of bones is heard throughout
the house she's singing happy birthday
to gemma who is unseen gemma's voice can
be heard begging for food another crack
this time from the ceiling dust falls
from above the house is giving out gemma
screams that she's in pain and that she
doesn't want to fall the cracking gets
louder and before melanie can finish
singing she's taken back by the horror
of the situation gemma begs for her
mother to help her and that her back
hurts the ceiling's about to give out
any second and suddenly it does the
camera tips showing a ceiling full of
cracks which gives out over the next few
seconds melanie screams that she'll
catch gemma but she is simply too big
her form is revealed a block of barely
human skin and tissue
shaped into a square mass due to being
confined to the walls for years you
can't tell that the entity before you is
still human and most of all an injured
scared child
gemma's anomalous growth when confined
to such a small space over a long period
of time resulted in this gemma falls to
the floor crushing melanie in the
process for the remaining four hours of
the tape gemma sifts and struggles all
while crying out for her mother the tape
stops disturbed by the content you know
you're going to feel sick transcribing
these tapes you check the corresponding
database file for
scp-6670 in hopes you can access it
thankfully it's within your clearance
and all is illuminated when you read
what's already there
scp-6670 is gemma described as a large
amorphous entity made of flesh tissue
and contorted bones scp-66
is confined to a small house in detroit
michigan where it's been contained on
site with a concrete wall constructed
around the home
scp-6670 was discovered following the
recording of the tape when passers-by
outside the house described the
structure as
breathing after which containment
measures were implemented and research
began the only access point to
scp-6670 is through the doorway outside
the bedroom as most of the house's
structure is either destroyed or taken
up by
scp-6670's mass x-ray scans revealed
that
scp-6670 spine is extremely contorted
and is assumed to have grown along the
dimensions of the home with puberty
assumed to have accelerated the growing
process
scp-6670 is largely immobile and is
believed to be hibernating its
intelligence seems to be roughly
equivalent to a small child inside the
home the tapes were found and the file
describes them as a waiting
transcription which is your job beneath
the section intended for your work is an
event log transcribed by personnel
working on site with scp-6670
the entity after remaining immobile for
so long had eventually moved the log
read as follows the entity rolled in
front of the camera where its mouth
could be seen it's surrounded by several
strings of rotting flesh and caked with
blood the teeth are rotten consistent
with typical patterns of tooth decay a
clump of black hair clings to the side
of its lower lip
scp-6670 is heard speaking the camera
registers the sound as similar to
mama i'm hungry it's voice is that of a
young girl you're taken back by the
graphic bodily alteration described when
the realization hits you that you're
going to have to watch these tapes
multiple times over to ensure proper
transcription but then one other thing
stands out a clump of black hair on scp
6670's lip but gemma had blonde hair and
then it hits you you know that you'll be
in for many sleepless nights after this
is all said and done
now go check out scp-002 the living room
and the most terrifying scp rooms and
scp-2432 room service for more super
weird human body contorted rooms and
spaces